foreign
he's an Orthodox icon Carver from Quebec
and the chief editor of the Orthodox
Arts Journal
he's cultivated a community of artists
authors and creators and given them
space on his symbolic World blog
he also explores symbolism and art
literature philosophy and popular
culture and talks he's given around the
world and his YouTube channel also
called symbolic world
he recently published a graphic novel
God's dog
please join me in welcoming Jonathan
pajel
[Applause]
so first off I really would really like
to thank Eamon and Catherine and Scott
for this amazing event and this amazing
opportunity
you know
um this discussion these discussions
we've been having for years now I guess
it's becoming have been um
they've just been wonderful to to you
saw it yesterday like there's a what
I've been seeing what I've been feeling
is this this desire to understand each
other desire to enter into real
communication with each other and uh and
I'm like I'm now I'm also I'm almost
used to it right I'm used to it and so
I'm looking at the content and the and
yesterday a few people were telling me
Oh you know my father was here and he
was just amazed at the at the generosity
and the discussion like yeah I have to
always remember that that's actually the
basis of why we're even able to have
these discussions
um and so I want to thank all of you for
coming here I was
right from the first day when people
started arriving I was just amazed at
how much people have been following this
discussion and how I felt the same
generosity and and openness to listen
and to engage that I felt when I talked
to John or when I talked to Paul
um the big confession I have to make is
that oh I last night I suffered greatly
I was in so much pain because I was
sitting right there and I had John and
Paul up here
and and and they were talking and
exchanging and I was like you could
probably see me like I was right on the
edge of my seat I was like I want to
jump up there and uh and get into the
conversation
uh so but I didn't I was respectful and
uh so I
so I thought I'm gonna so hope as I'm
hoping that I can make them suffer a
little bit this morning
I'll say a bunch of things yeah and so
it's funny because yesterday
Paul was standing up here and he said
are you gonna wing it and uh and he was
like struggling with that and I prepared
to talk and but with everything
everybody said
I I was just I went downstairs you know
a little bit to kind of Center myself
and pray a little bit and and I thought
am I just going to do the talk or am I
going to engage and I think I'm gonna
engage more than just do the talk and so
hopefully it's going to come together in
terms of I'm gonna deal with a lot of
the things that John talked about and
Paul talked about yesterday and I'm
going to try to pull them together
basically into my talk that I had
prepared uh today
um
so I really wanted to at the outset I
wanted to dive into the the theme of the
conference which was this idea of
Consciousness and conscience and I think
the
the framing of the conference was a way
to maybe try to help us think about or
look at how is it that conscious
experience consciousness
um
how is it related to
morality I don't like the word morality
I rarely use it I would rather use the
good if that's okay with you and I'll
we'll move into why I use that that term
it has a long history
and this is something for those who
followed my my own discussions it's
something that I've been fascinated with
from the beginning which is the problem
of what John calls combinatorial
explosion the problem of framing as we
approach reality that is we we realize
that phenomena is too complex as an
artist it's something that most anybody
who's a painter or an artist
you come to realize that very fast
because if you sit in front of something
and you're trying to draw it or paint it
I was talking to someone today who is
explaining that that experience
uh you realize there's way too much
stuff out there and I actually have to
find a through line I have to discover I
have to engage with a structure which is
hidden or there potentially in the thing
that I'm looking at and
one of the things I realized when I was
in my 20s was that actually that's
probably how we deal with most things
that we have to find a through line as
John the term that John's uses which I
like a lot as we frame phenomena and
what I think is I think that if we
understand it that way and we look at it
that way we're going to come
to a manner of understanding how the
good
uh arises from that um and so one of the
things you realize and this is you've
heard me talk about the glass a million
times if you watch any of my videos but
one of the things you realize is that
when you engage with things in the world
uh you engage with them with a purpose
so like our categories are not just abs
are not just concrete categories that
are completely arbitrary but that they
start at least they start in categories
of
engagement right so it's like a glass is
something it's a container it's
something that I drink from and that's
why I care about it and that's why I
care enough about it for me to have a
category for it or for me to engage with
it in a manner that
that makes it hold together as a
phenomena because what we what we
realize is that phenomena is it is
combinatory explosive there are many
aspects to this like we could say you
know what is it the example that's
always used is I could use this as a as
a weapon I could use it to prop up
something I could it has all kinds of
possibilities in it but I engage with it
as I engage with it then it it manifests
itself to us as
and identity and that identity is almost
in some way it's identical with its good
that is when I perceive a glass I'm
always judging whether it's a good glass
because I want to drink from it like if
I'm walking out on the floor and I'm
doing it unconsciously you know some
ways or I'm not doing fully consciously
I'm always asking myself whether or not
the floor is gonna hold me or I trust
that it's going to hold me because
that's why that's why I have a category
for it in the first place and it's the
same with even
it's sometimes it looks harder when we
look at the scientific categories
but the scientific categories are framed
first of all in our experience
categories there's the just the
experience that we have every day and so
we why is it even in terms of science
why is it that some aspects of science
get more funding get more attention than
others it's because they're always
couched in categories of care ultimately
they're couching what is important to us
in terms of humans
um
and so what I what I realized uh a while
ago is that I think that that's what
Dante is talking about in the Comedia
and so I've been really thinking a lot
about the way that Dante engages with
with uh the way that he sees the this
movement that humans have out into the
world and he talks about it exactly in
that way he he couches it in two Notions
which is love the love and the good that
is all humans perceive a good
toward which they move and that they at
least think or at least hope that they
will find rest in that good
and so if you think about it every
single one of your movements and
anything that you do can be framed that
way that is I walk into a room I have a
reason why I'm walking to a room it can
be a very very minimal reason it could
be a small good but it has to be a good
or else I wouldn't I wouldn't move I
would just stand here paralyzed like but
if I'm moving somewhere I'm moving in a
direction towards something if I grab
something I'm doing it for a reason and
it's always because I'm looking to rest
in a good if I grab a glasses because I
think I if I drink it I will find a good
there and if I
you know if I'd walk into a building if
I go to shopping mall if I do anything I
do and sometimes that good can just be
you know if I want to go for a walk and
I want to
free my clear my mind or whatever it is
every single
every single motion we do and it's I
think it's probably actually most of the
time true even for things that we're not
totally conscious of that we actually
act towards Goods we protect ourselves
from things that will hurt us and we
move towards things that we recognize as
as being good and so
the reason why I'm talking about this is
because that's I think related to the
problem of the combinatorial explosion
problem
which is
the categories that we have and the
categories we even perceive in the world
are related to their good so you know an
apple is it a good apple that means a
different thing than uh a good chair or
a good anything or even even in terms of
science it's super interesting because
because scientists when they study
something they will they will reduce
all the parameters down to their
variables that they're looking for and
they will they'll create a a frame and
then they will have to judge whether or
not the facts they're looking at fit the
good that they're aiming for there's no
other way to do it so you have to decide
I'm studying this for this reason and
now I have to see which facts because
I'm obviously if I'm studying
I'm studying a rhinoceros right it's
like I'm not going to be looking at the
clouds because that doesn't that doesn't
fit in the good that I'm looking for and
even even if I'm studying a rhinoceros I
have to study the rhinoceros in a
certain direction in a certain frame a
certain aspect of it and then all the
facts I'm going to see which facts fit
in that good and some of them which
don't fit so much there's always going
to be things that are going to be kind
of on the margin and I have to decide
where do I cut off where do I
remove remove the facts that don't fit
into the good that I'm caring about and
which ones do and then I can get to the
the purpose that I'm doing so even
science actually functions in that
manner in the the process so often
people will then describe the results of
Science and say well here are these
objective results and everything but
those objective results are always
couched in someone
searching for a good
and organizing facts towards a purpose
and then deciding not deciding or
perceiving which facts fit and aim at
the good that they're that they're
trying to find and sometimes a scientist
will
will will identify a good will start to
organize facts towards that and they'll
realize that no the facts just don't
they don't actually you can't reach that
the the thing that I'm doing my theory
doesn't work so I have to find a new
Theory to try to gather these facts
together
uh if I'm going to make sense of of the
world
um
and so
what are the things that I've one of the
things that I that I've been thinking of
is that
that I think is ultimately
just that is the source of morality or
the source of the good we we see the
good in things but then there's a manner
in which
as soon as that becomes a question of
people or as soon as that becomes a
question of others that I see in them a
reflection of of myself I see them as
like me then the good of
the good of the glass which is there to
drink out of becomes a different kind of
good but it's not there's nonetheless
that and in Dante that's the way that
it's presented
to us is that Dante
and it has to do with love that is love
is the thing that draws you towards the
good one one of the one of the things I
think about in terms of Dante is that we
often complain about how in Latin and in
the romance languages we reduce all the
words for love that we're in Greek
because in Greek they have you know you
have was it seven words for love or five
words for love and they've reduced them
to one and so we lost so much but I
think that although maybe we did lose
there's also something that we gain
which is we gain the notion of just the
idea of something which draws you
towards something else just that like
what is it that draws you towards
something else and then you say well
that's love so it is Eros you know but
that it's also Agape because Agape is
also that which carries me into the
other like this this open like movement
towards the other but it always is it's
like a motor that makes you move and
it's a it's a great way to frame it
because then you can actually you can
apply it like I said to all the things
you do because you know whether it is
whether I'm brushing my teeth or whether
you know I'm avoiding a puddle all of
these things that I'm doing are always
uh I love drawing me towards the good
and trying to avoid the things that are
in my way or trying to to emphasize the
things that are drawing me towards the
good
but when we encounter people then people
become
for us
they become for us places or things that
can draw us into
a different kind of good and so in Dante
what happens in him is that he finds
himself right in this dark place finds
himself basically in a place of nihilism
a place of he's he can't move he's stuck
that's the that is the that's the place
where you have no good and you have no
love and and we've all experienced
moments like that and we know people
that fall into that someone who's
depressed can be physically fit they're
completely physically in good shape they
could do all the things if they
physically but they can't find
a purpose to move and they can't light a
love to get them to move and so they
when they lay in bed all day and you're
like well just get up and do something
but there's no love
there's no draw there's nothing pulling
me forward
um and so Dante finds himself in that
spot
and
the first thing that makes him move is
he encounters the poet
and the the poet
reveals to him
Beauty
something which is calling him
and so Dante is a little bit you could
say it's not like a little bit of love
is kindled in him where he he also
remembers
something that had driven him before
it's good that had pulled him forward
and so he encounters the poet which
is the one who taught him about
love maybe the first thing that kindled
even the notion of love in him and that
made him understand but it's a person
and that's why I
it's not it's not an abstract thing
and and this is actually going to I hope
at some point it's going to also help
people understand religion a little
better is that humans are driven
towards the good in people like we're
not abstractly driven towards morality
we don't very few people will act
towards abstract moral principles but
people will be drawn into examples and
and people who reveal to you in their
persons things that I want to imitate
right that's how children learn that's
how we that's how we exist together and
often we we forget that because then we
we find these ethical codes and we have
all these ethical rules but we we forget
that
humans
see in others and we move towards others
we we're drawn into others and we move
we move in the the
in the example of others
so that's what Dante experiences it's
like Virgil
is an example of someone who embodied
Beauty someone who was able to manifest
love in a
a more exterior form right in poems and
literature all of that and that has a
powerful value but it's not enough for
Dante and that Virgil leads him
ultimately to Beatrice and Beatrice now
there is an example of an actual erotic
Awakening that he had in his life where
it's like this woman captured him
and gave him a motor right gave him a
motor at first towards her but then in
the story we see that his love was
unrequited he wasn't able to to to
engage with her
ah but it's a person it's a person
that's kind of drawing him forward
and of course if you know the story of
Dante then those people that he
encounters they pull him
further and they pull him into heaven
and so
this can also help you understand what
heaven is because it's just so hard for
the modern world to to realize that that
in Dante heaven
our people
they are they they are people that
embody the virtues that lead us towards
the good
and so that's they are Saints they are
characters and have all through and it's
the same even with the bad stuff it's
all people it's all encounters with
people that model
sin that model passion that model
excessive moderate that model violence
and then it moves up into people that
model virtue and that model the good
more and more embedded into each other
so when when Dante ascends the Heavenly
spheres
it's there's a reason why those heavenly
spheres are inhabited by people that
exemplify these this scale of goods this
scale of Virtues and it's funny because
even in the text because you know I
think Dante
this is I think this is something which
would have been completely just obvious
to a medieval person it was just
something that's completely normal to
understand but Dante was like in this
interesting transition period I think he
probably felt that he was in this
transition period And so to warn the
like Star Trek science fiction reader
for of the future
uh Beatrice at some point tells Dante
he's like wait the souls don't actually
inhabit these Heavenly spheres okay so
just speak like be careful like they
don't this is that we're not idiots like
there aren't Souls like up in these in
these uh whatever Circles of Heaven that
are kind of hanging out there like
looking down that's not what we're
saying we're saying that
the experience of the of the heavens the
experience of this Ascension or
hierarchy of that which is above you
is there to
and how does he say it she says
she says at first you need your senses
like we we get things from senses and
from our sensual experience we then know
what is fit for mind but it all starts
in the the sense so it's like it's not
that the souls inhabit the Heavenly
spheres but that if you understand that
which is above you
the experience of that which is above
then you can understand why these Souls
that inhabit different virtues move up
into greater and greater Goods
um
and so then he he has these experiences
he moves up into the good and then he
ends up in the final moment right into
the love that moves all things that's
how the poem finishes he finishes with
him entering into the love that moves
all things and you realize that the
whole home was about
love and about what draws us into these
Goods now my
my contention is that I think that Dante
is helping us understand the manner in
which attention functions
in the most immediate way that it's not
he's not just describing a moral system
he's not just describing but he's
actually helping us understand the
manner in which attention
functions through care
and desire for a good and that is
actually how categorization
functions obviously he wouldn't actually
probably have cared about this more
scientific question but I think that
that's he's giving us a manner to
understand the process of Framing and of
categorization
uh but he's doing it in the way that is
the most important which is
understanding that all of this is
couched in our experience of each other
and of people that draw us into
that which is good
and so I think one of the things that
that does
one of the things that that does so I'm
gonna just before
uh Dante enters into the highest sphere
right why just before it enters into the
love that moves the universe the Trinity
as the image of that love that is this
multiplicity and unity which coexists
together right the possibility of
drawing the many into one that's the
problem of attention itself and the
problem of understanding how those
coexist they they coexist in love and
it's not an arbitrary
it's not just an arbitrary thing because
it's the problem you face with the glass
as well because the glass is not one
thing right the glass is a bunch of
things and it's a bunch of things that
are a bunch of things but nonetheless
for some reason
we are able to see that it's one like
what is going on and I think the answer
to that is love or you don't like the
word love because it's too sappy like
let's just use the word care we could
say use the word Heidegger used that's
fine if that's what drives us into
seeing unity in multiplicity is is love
of the good that that one gives you
whatever that one is like whatever thing
you see as one a car is not one thing
right cars and millions and millions of
things but nonetheless you're able to
perceive it as one because it gives it
offers you a good that draws you into
itself and so
that's also true for
let's say at the Primal level it's
something that you could find for all
the categories it's a phenomenon I'm
also
let's say
ing that the phenomenological experience
of reality is Primal it's before
whatever scientific categories you give
so the reality of a of a tree is first
phenomenologically the good that it
offers and then if you want to start
breaking down its cell structure that is
helpful and it and it's fine but that
there's a there's a there's a good in
which we first even know that a tree is
one thing
because I know it sounds it sounds
obvious because we all experience it all
the time that we just see unity and we
think that it's an obvious like oh
that's the it's just one thing well it's
not well it is but it's not and that's
the problem that I think Dante is giving
us some image of
and that's why I do believe that that I
think that that's the highest
I think that it is one of the reasons
why we have the image of the Trinity is
to bring that mystery into the highest
good and to the source of all things you
can say the source of all things is one
in many at the same time it is a perfect
union perfect multiplicity and so it
brings us into this image of what the
source of reality is and if we say that
if we don't and and it's actually a
problem-solving thing it's it's I do
believe that it's true I am a Christian
like it's a revelation but it is also a
problem-solving thing because the
systems that look at the unity of all
things as a as a monad as an absolute
monad they tend to understand
multiplicity as degenerative they always
tend to move towards the notion that the
multiple becomes evil in itself that as
you move from the one to the many you're
moving into evil itself so you see
different Gnostic systems that have that
structure and so
of course the problem of positing just
some I think very few systems would do
that but just positing some multiplicity
as the origin the complete origin I mean
just means that we're just gonna be
fighting all the time we're just gonna
everything's going to be at war with
each other because there's no notion of
unity which holds it together
um so I think the Trinity is there to
I think one of the aspects of the
trinity in the context of this
conversation can help us understand that
that is how especially in let's say even
in the way that Dante presents it the
notion of when we say God is love it's
not just a Sentimental
thing that we're saying we're saying
that the source of reality is bound in
this principle that draws us together
but also doesn't reduce us to one
because that's also one of the important
aspects of Love is that
if I love you I don't want to be
I want you to exist as different from me
right because if we collapse the
difference between you and I then
there's nothing to love anymore right so
there's a there's a sense in which as I
approach the thing I love I wanted both
I both want to be United with it but I
also wanted to have a certain
distinction from myself or else it
cannot be a source of a source that
draws me and so the notion that those
two those two aspects of love which is
one the unity and multiplicity
coexisting basically is the
is the way that I I see it as helping to
solve this a lot of these problems
the other aspect what's important when
you think of how Dante ascends is that
before he let's say before he encounters
the Trinity he encounters Christ
and I and I really do think
I really do think that Christ
offers some Technical Solutions to some
of the problems that we're dealing with
so if you don't want to believe in Jesus
Christ let's just at least start with
the notion of the anointed or Christ the
idea of the son of man which we find in
Scripture
because one of the problems we've been
having and everybody's been talking
about is how is it that
how is it that these higher beings or
that these
distributed cognitions how is it that
they exist or do they have Consciousness
how do they have Consciousness is it
possible how is it that their causal how
do they hold together
um
and one of the things I think the
ancients started to posit as a solution
to that is something like Heavenly Man
and you find that in the Bible when the
image of the son of man but you find it
also in early uh in early but actually
in first century Jewish thinkers Philo
of Alexander for example he talked about
this idea Adam Cadman where Universal
Man
um
and the reason why I think it's an
important category because we often hear
people say things like that they don't
realize it but they'll say things you
know like
even like I'll use an example like Santa
Claus like they'll say something like
well Santa Claus doesn't exist it's just
something humans came up with and I'm
like okay
humans came up with like who are these
humans and is it one human like is it
can you name them like can you find the
people that came up with these things
like can you find the people that came
up with the structure of a family or the
structure of a Nation like are you going
to who are these humans so people said
that it only exists because people say
oh or people say something like gold
only has value because we decide it does
and like really who is this we that
decide that gold has value right are you
do you have the power to change that go
ahead my friend like you you do that you
change that you make that not true
anymore go ahead and make sure that gold
doesn't you know if it's just a
completely subjective thing that we come
up with then go ahead stop that make it
stop right that's not how these things
work there seems to be there seems to be
driving
uh Wills that are higher than our
individual will that are managing these
things but those Wills seem to be a
reflection in just as the people are
saying seems to be a kind of mirror of
human of a human will it's a it's a
human good that it's looking for it's
not a it's not some random thing right
so it's like you can imagine that
someone that that the image of Santa
Claus
it's feeling a
function that has some good whether you
agree with it or not that has some
function that is driving people to
participate in that the value of gold is
the same thing like the you can't just
decide the value of gold seems to have
some good it's aiming to you could then
decide whether the good is is parasitic
or whether it's where it has a more more
to it than just that uh but it there's
something driving that and so and and I
do think that that's ultimately
the notion of The Heavenly Man is
helping us deal with so you could
understand that positing of a
of a man with a capital M that stands at
the right hand of God and that rules
over all things
and so
in even in the Bible if you know your
New Testament and you start to think
about it you can start to see that
sometimes it seems that that's what
Saint Paul or the or the the Bible is
suggesting that is going on which is
something like the Angels so these
principalities that are above us these
distributed cognitions that we encounter
that we can see have agency over us
they're about they are above us in sense
that we're we're kind of subject to
their causality
but there's a manner in which you could
say something like
they are meant to serve man
is meant to rule over them so you'll
find texts like that in Saint Paul where
it's like we are meant to rule with
Christ like we're meant to rule with the
angel we're meant to be in the Council
of God ruling over these even over even
over the Angels but I think it's also
technically like just in terms of
understanding how these these emanating
group distributed cognitions happen is
that they are
ultimately the product of man with a
capital M that they serve man or they
don't serve man or you can find versions
of it that
are distorted and lead us into places
where we don't
where we didn't think was possible a
good example is the genie is a good
story for that right and so you have a
higher level principality which appears
to someone
and then is at your service
and the the principality says what do
you want
you can get whatever you want
and it's like a test of virtue it's a
test of where are you let's say on the
scale of goods and so if you and then
what you ask for you'll get
but because you're not high enough on
the left on the scale of goods you're
going to get all the side effects that
you weren't conscious enough or you
weren't concentrated enough to get so
you're going to get what you wanted and
then all the side effects come with it
so a good example of that is a Facebook
that's probably one of the best examples
to understand is that I really don't
think that that Zuckerberg is a bad guy
at the origin I think he's just naive
he's very smart and naive and he's like
we're gonna make this thing
this community and it's going to have
this these functionalities
uh
and he never really asked himself what
good is it serving ultimately and he
also there's a secret reason why it
exists that they don't tell you which is
ultimately to make money
and so that's actually the secret reason
behind let's say Facebook and so because
of that
no matter what functionality they put
into it the only thing it wants from you
is your attention that's all it wants it
has your attention it runs it doesn't
have your attention it doesn't
and the way that it the reason why I
want your attention because it monetizes
your attention
and so so then you have this thing which
manifests itself a being
that has agency over us that that has
power over us ultimately
but because it is not serving the proper
good it becomes parasitic and it gets
out of control and it starts to to
manifest all these things that are that
weren't intended in the first place but
that were there if you had looked at the
good that it was serving at the outset
and so it has so you could say that
Facebook is supposed it was supposed to
serve man it was supposed to be an
emergent an emergent uh
say an emerging community that was there
to serve the the needs of man but
because it had
a goal which was to make money just or
that was like the first goal then
everything else starts to get wobbly and
then you realize that it ends up serving
the darker aspects of ourselves
it just ends up serving your passions
you could say so it becomes distorted
and then because you realize that the
easiest way to get someone's attention
or it is not to propose to them the good
that's actually it hurts it hard it
takes effort it's difficult it's to show
you it's to make you angry it's to get
you excited it's to it's to just
stimulate the lower aspects of your your
desires and that's how it'll get your
your attention
but then you can understand then you can
understand like say Facebook
that that this causal pattern that it is
causal it actually has causes behavior
in us and it brings us together towards
purposes
uh
that it is at once
it is that it is at once above us
but it should or if it if you wanted it
to work well it would have been in the
service of man you could say like end
now with a capital m
um and I think that that at least in
terms of the problem of understanding
the consciousness of
higher order beings I think it's
probably Saint Maximus now becomes the
the key to that again which is that
we see these higher structures through
human consciousness
and that is completely
the right way to see it that human
consciousness becomes the like the the
Crux of how these higher level beings
exist and that is totally fine but it
only works if we have a kind of
distilled
man right a a man which is I mean the
best the image is The Heavenly Man a man
that that is all that man can and should
be ready it's the highest image of what
man is and it gets pulled into one one
place and he becomes like an image of
what that is so and I think that that's
what in the in the Old Testament the
notion of the son of man was and so the
son of man receives from God all power
and authority over the world you see
that in the Book of Daniel right so it's
like the son of man descends from heaven
and has all the power of God but is the
the Heavenly image of man in the world
and I think that
I think that without that image and so
you see it you see it then used in the
the Renaissance new platonist they'll
have versions of that right where
they'll have
Leonardo da Vinci's perfect man or you
have different Notions of this ideal
idealized man that
that the Renaissance thinkers will try
to bring into the conversation to make
sense of
the microcosm and macrocosm problem
um but I do think that no matter how we
we look at it that might be a really
good place to look
for us to be able to talk about the
question of of distributed cognition or
the manner in which principalities exist
because they do have
so right the image that Saint Paul talks
about right so Saint Paul talks about
these principalities and powers that are
managing us and he says something like
Christ is at this moment secretly
ascending and dominate dominating over
the principalities and Powers
that is the image that was given to us
of Man in Christ
now this is where I'm going straight
into the Christian the Christian idea
that it it it does reveal to us the
image of what
the proper image of man which will rule
properly over the principalities
and that has to a certain extent to do
with the problem that you're talking
about yesterday in terms of the multiple
Consciousness positions like the
multiple eyes
because what you realize is that the man
the height and this is I think it's also
a way it was scandalous when the story
burst out into the world is that
the man that is The Heavenly Man is the
one who is willing to die
is the one who is willing to let go
of all these
eye positions and that looks like
die
it's a it's a it's a self-sacrifice
he's willing to sacrifice all these
self little selves in order to enter
into
the ground of being that that John was
talking about yesterday
and so the
so the the story of Christ like the
image of Jesus on the cross
so bothersome it's so weird you know you
go into a church and of course we're
used to it but it's like why do we have
this dead guy
looking at us right from the East where
the sun rises it's like the origin he's
the origin right so this guy on the
cross is the origin um
Saint Maximus says crazy things like he
said things that sound crazy at the
outfit but I think they're quite
reasonable he says he says when Christ
was on the cross he was creating the
world
yeah
that's not gonna fit that in a
scientific textbook but
laughs
the act the let's say if you can imagine
and perfect ACT of self-sacrifice
that act is the origin of
the principalities right it's the or is
the origin of the proper order
of the world
and that if
if that happens
then things lay themselves out under it
in the right way so you could say in
terms of your mystical
experiences or the way that Mystics talk
about it right and so they all these
things that they use ego death or
whatever all these types of terms that
they use is that
if you reach that point behind
the eye positions you enter into a space
which both recognizes that none of these
positions have existence in themselves
but that they all have existence because
they are held together in this place
of uh
this place which in some ways is beyond
particular care but is like the source
of all care you could say right it's
like it's it's beyond a particular love
but it's the source of all loves
um and so I I really do
I really do believe that
the story of Jesus if we start to think
of it even in terms of the conversations
we're having we'll be able to reveal
some things about
why the story looks the way it does
because
it's a it's a it's a very strange and
it's a very strange story you think like
why is it that that story and so even as
a secular materialist it's like why did
that story become
the backbone of Western thinking why did
that story become the backbone of
Western thinking on morality because we
and even like I think most people today
will believe something like that
self-sacrifice has value it's like
really I mean okay
but why like why why do you think that
or why do you think that self-sacrifice
has a
has a causal causes the world to exist
properly and I've been thinking about
about that a lot in terms of trying to
understand how we also categorize things
and and I mentioned this with it but I
want to go just before I end I want to
go through it because I want you to see
that I know it's hard let's speak for
people that are
if they use to the Christian language
and and it's hard because sometimes you
just hear the story and you have this
barrier it's I I get it but
if if for something to exist
as one
the multiple aspects of that thing
whatever it is
because they do all they could also
exist in other ways they have millions
of other ways in which they could exist
right they could have other functions
other
they have to give themselves
to the one
okay so of course that you remember what
I said you could say it happens through
men that's totally fine I'm not saying
that the parts of the glass have this
will that they're giving up their will
and that they're moving towards the
unity of the glass like I'm not saying
that but if that's how you want to
understand that's also fine whatever I'm
just trying to help understand that
there's an there's a need for
idiosyncrasy to be sacrificed
towards the whole
and that is how things actually cohere
into one so self-sacrifice is at the
origin
of the unity in things and there's also
a manner in which the one also has to
give itself to the many
because
nothing is perfect you have to right so
it's like if I imagine the form of the
glass almost in the platonics it's the
perfect glass
if there has to be a kind of flexibility
to let multiplicity be possible Right to
let the glass exist make of one miss out
of wood or out of glass out of metal
have different sizes there has to be a
kind of a kind of giving up of the
purity of of the one so that the Manny
can exist this is of course something if
you in any team or in any group you'll
definitely at some point see that
there's a there can be the goal of the
team or the goal of whatever it is we're
doing and that will be that which draws
us together we're going to give our
idiosyncrasies to that right so if I'm
if I'm playing a sport if I'm playing
basketball
I'm not hanging out with my girlfriend
I'm not like doing other things I am
giving away I'm sacrificing all these
aspects of me in order to give myself to
this Unity that I'm participating in
so I'm joined together with others I'm
I'm I'm doing it in love towards a good
and so it's a there's a sacrificial
aspect to that but there's also a manner
in which
the team that I'm participating in also
has to give itself to the players it has
to it has to kind of say give itself in
love to the players and care about even
the players
The Players let's say idiosyncrasies or
the things about the players which don't
totally fit I have to I have to have
give some mercy towards that or else
because nobody is a perfect basketball
player
nobody is just a basketball player there
will be that messiness and so I I have
to the the one has to give itself to the
many and the many have to give itself to
the one for for that to exist and that's
what I think
I think that that's one of the things I
think that Christ
let's say reveals
in his story
and I think that's probably also why
after Christ
after the story of Christ the
sacrificial system ends pretty much
everywhere
like the actual physicals you know
scapegoat sacrifices and all these types
of of physical ritualized sacrifice they
they all tend to kind of Peter out
because he's revealing a different mode
of of sacrifice which is actually more
primordial to how things work and that
and it's the that's actually it's like
actually self-sacrifice is the way so if
you want your family to bind together
you can do it with a black sheep it
works by the way so you can have a
member of your family that's a black
sheep and you can just put all the blame
on them whatever problems your family
has it's their fault whatever whatever
issue they have and you'll find unity in
blaming the black sheep it'll work I'm
telling it it's like it's their fault
and now we love each other more because
we know it's their fault right and you
see it it's happening right now like all
the scapegoating it's it's crazy sadly
coming back again
and then what Christ reveals is that no
actually the proper mode of sacrifice is
self-sacrifice so if you want your
family to cohere and you're a father you
have to give yourself
to the whole and if you do that it has a
it's much more powerful and will create
much more Unity than the scapegoat part
and then the same for the group the
group it's like it's actually if I
sacrifice my idiosyncrasy towards this
common good then I
it's the best way for Unity and
multiplicity to coexist
um and so I so I hopefully I've been I'm
going over my time sorry so hopefully
this is just the thought that I've had
regarding
Dante and the notion of the good but
also related to the problem even
categorization and how
higher beings can be said to exist uh
and not
because we've been struggling for for
months now everybody's struggling about
talking about Edgar gors and all these
different terms they're trying to talk
about to talk to to discuss how these
higher patterns are causal
um and I really do think that the notion
of man or distilled man is the way to
that it goes through that it's like a
filter
it's like the the notion of man is this
fault is this filter that makes these
principalities uh
causal on us kind of accept it
implicitly because we recognize that
they serve
the good even if we're wrong we
recognize that they serve the good of
man
uh and even if we like I said even if
we're off on that it's still that
because in Dante all the bad things you
do are also driven by love it's just
distorted right it's like if if you
become a becoming a drug addict is love
love is what makes you become a drug
addict right love is what makes you
become
become uh anything like cheat on your
wife or whatever bad thing that you're
going to do it's always love towards a
perceived good that drives you towards
it and you can get it wrong but it's
still the same structure so anyways
hopefully that was helpful a little bit
in the discussion I wasn't too rambly
because I was doing trying to bring it
together and uh yeah thanks you for your
attention
thank you